um how much like obviously the album
comes out on the 20th right yeah yeah
next Friday um
how are you are you like going to stay
like pretty active with music or you
kind of going to put this out let it
live and then see how you feel as of now
I'm going
to stay active until I'm needed there's
the rejects yeah reject yeah rejects
going to come too um and then after this
I'mma start I got over 2,000 unreleased
records I'm going to start letting
records out I'm going start letting the
wild Factor records out you see what I'm
saying cuz one thing people don't
realize in the industry I probably have
the most powerful relationships that is
you're not going to you can't find
nobody who's been featured more or has
more features than me the closest would
be two chains you know what I'm saying
and I'm and I'm pretty sure anybody tell
you like my relationships is something
way different man so I think I'm going
to get to a point where I just start
releasing a bunch of crazy records for
the fun of it yeah cuz why sit on them
man I'm sitting on 2000 records plus so
I I've been sitting on them a long time
that's crazy but I don't I don't really
I do it just for my own personal M you
know even though my people say it's
selfish but just do it for my own
personal huh like when you go to the
studio that's that's that's my go-to you
know I don't smoke or drink that's
that's my go-to but um Not only would it
being my
uh my go-to it's
like when it come times with situations
going on I have to pick be there for the
people or focus on myself and I
always you know what I'm saying I always
pick the people so I never really get to
get the fair shot this is the first time
nothing's really fully interrupted me
from trying to push a put an album out
so I'm just living it while I can to
next [__] hitting I got to get back to
it yo is Texas open carry yeah yeah yeah
yeah do you cuz you know like we're in
California where they make it extremely
difficult to like protect
yourself and uh you know there's good
things and bad things about that
obviously there there's a terrible
school shooting that happened in Texas
in day
I was there that's see that you know I'm
front line for all that I was that was a
heartbreaking situation yeah yeah may
they rest in peace man I am like
typically a liberal guy but I do feel
like our our countryes move so past like
ever changing the gun culture this is
just who we are like we are the United
States like I think that there should be
like obvious um background checks like
very common sense things but I just
wonder for you like do you feel like in
Texas certain [__] doesn't happen as
often because people think twice about
so it's the give and the curse right
it's the give and the curse people think
twice one cuz [__] the person you
thinking of going may have exactly what
you have so you you're not really trying
to right feel that you know what I'm
saying you you you have that but then
it's
like the curse is damn you ow some of
the the goofies that just do stupid [__]
that don't stand on principle or nothing
and been and accidentally hurt a child
something else so you know it's the it's
the gift and the curse with it man which
is like it's almost like here like the
gift and the curse of California is like
you know there's not as much like I
guess it's not as easy to just go to a
Walmart and buy AR-15 and go shoot up a
[__] your workplace or a school it's
very hard to do that the curse is you
might get ran up on and there really
like like it's active I'm sure you've
seen the smash and grabs and people in
the bay get bipped every [__] day
like it's it's wild like so it's kind of
like it's kind of like you got to pick
your poison a little bit and it's
unfortunate but this is America cuz you
ain't never going to get rid of the guns
no no no matter what there's too many of
them too much big business no man
but believe it or not you just you have
to I've learned to adapt to my
environment but I'm going to tell you
one thing that really really got to me
right I was one day cuz I like my son
Houston you know he's um
13 I expose him to the game yeah like I
he's he's going to have both smarts he
can be a square and a street kid at the
same time just so he'll
know what to do what not to do and if I
expose it to him no child can come key
him up and excite him to go do no crash
dummy [__] cuz it's pops and already
showed him so um I was like man you know
what [__] it let's let's just go to the
gun range right but in my mind is like
damn I don't want people sitting here
whining cuz he young man I went in there
it was kids seven the 8 years old all
the way up this the um this place super
pack yeah but my point of saying that is
people are already preparing to and
they're already adapting to their their
environment and and you never know I
mean shis getting it can get real and
the world is getting real right now in
general mhm yeah now I I twister does uh
a good job in uh Chicago he has classes
so you know I it's crazy I told him he
going to have to come I I told him we
were well we ended up doing trade day so
we didn't get around to it then I just
had my listening party in Chicago he
came out um shout out to him Raul but
yeah I told him yeah he going to have to
train me to make sure I can be a
sharpshooter I'm I'm going to take some
time yeah he's really good at like he's
training like people how to properly own
a weapon at a pro like like you know
what I'm saying like cuz at the end of
the day like that's something that I
think in the black community isn't
taught you know what I'm saying you got
to realize man [__] from where we come
from back in the Gap we used to think to
whole a gun sideway that you not hitting
none of we used to think it was Goofy
for people to be like that but [__] no
that's you got to have your aim yeah
yeah so yeah and a lot of people's lives
probably got saved because it was held
the wrong way to be that too yeah yeah
that's what's up man hey